any funny stories from your bachelor
party my bachelor party was pretty well
I don't know anything about it but that
pause made it sure seem like it was not
very tame
well it was tame as far as I was
concerned but there were some people
that got a little loopy one of my
friends ended up getting kicked out of a
strip club okay he went into the Boom
Boom Room with this girl right
and he kept asking instead of having the
dance he had them do impersonations
oh
he can kicked out because this one he
said this one woman Steve Harvey
impersonation was so bad he wouldn't pay
her
yeah but it wasn't that crazy but it was
the weirdest thing I was like
impersonations he was like yeah I
thought it'd be funny I was like for a
while it was yeah